[Music]
Hi everyone, I'm Yogi. I work at Faxet,
a financial data and software company.
And today I'll be sharing some of my
experience while building agent.
In last few years we have seen
tremendous growth in AI and especially
in last couple of years we are on
exponential curve of intelligence growth
and yet it feels like
when we are develop AI applications
driving a monster truck through a
crowded mall with a tiny joysticks. So
AI applications have not seen its charge
GPD moment yet.
There are many reasons why agents don't
behave but probably one reason that
strikes out is it misses the right
context
and in case of enterprises often it
means that it does not have knowledge of
enterprise specific workflows
but before that we will see some common
context and just like agents human also
need a common context so let's start
with some key definitions
So as you know LLMs are limited by their
knowledge at the time of training. So we
enhance their functionality by
increase it by tool. And when you
combine this LLM with tool and memory we
call it augmented LLM. When you place
this augmented LLM on a static and
predefined path we call it a workflow.
And if these augmented LLMs
have high autonomy and feedback loop, we
call it as an agent.
Now workflows are controllable and
reliable
while agents have flexibility and they
are highly autonomous. So the question
is can we get best of both worlds? So
the answer is yes. With agentic
workflows we can plan and execute the
workflows based on the goal, context and
feedback.
I see these terms being used very
loosely and at times interchangeably.
So I would like to make a key
distinction between workflow agent and
agentic workflow.
Workflow agent is a predefined workflow
run by agent
while agentic workflow is a workflow
planned and run by an agent.
I know these terms are like quite
confusing and in AI we are very bad at
naming things. So if you are confused
don't worry in case of workflow agent
just remember that workflow is in
control and workflow is static. In case
of agentic workflow agent is always in
control and the workflow is dynamic.
It is also important to view these
systems as agentic system. As Andrew
pointed out correctly
on agentic spectrum, agentic workflows
have more agenticness than workflow
agents. Generally speaking,
so why all of this matter?
Apart from control, reliability,
predictability
for enterprises,
agentic workflows provide a way to
automate the workflows at scale.
And perhaps most important thing is
enterprises can use their existing
enterprises uh microservices to build on
top of it. And in some cases
these enterprises have invested years
not if not decades.
So before diving deep I would like to
say that even though I'm speaking in
terms of enterprise context here the
concepts are generally applicable.
So where do we begin? In last few years
the focus really has been on the react
based agent and in building agentic
workflow we need to move on from react
based agent to proactive agents. By the
way great philosophy for life as well.
So for building agent workflows you need
tools, memory and reflection. But more
importantly you will need a design
pattern called planning by sub goal divi
sub goal division.
Sometimes also referred as a task
decomposition and it is just a fancy way
of saying that take your goal and break
it down into simpler steps.
Here are some specific agentic
architecture and research papers that
you will find useful and each of that
has like its own pro and cons and langun
has done fantastic job of uh creating a
blog from this and uh also given the
code. So I highly recommend checking it
out.
So how does it look in practice?
So what in in fact that what we have
done is we are taking this LLM compiler
architecture and trying to adop for our
problems
and you can see some components here uh
that you also find that in your
organization uh microservices
and you build tools around those
microservices and when a user question
ask it goes to blueprint generator and I
will get to that in a bit but consider
it as like a high level plan
what we call it is a blueprint print
that gets fed to planner. Planner is
your low level task. Planner it gives
the plan to the executor and executor is
supposed to execute it and joiner
combines the outputs from different
tasks
based on your replanning logic. Either
you do replanning again or you just like
terminate and give the response back to
the user.
Sometimes you also set some recussion
limit so that your agent just like
doesn't go into loop.
On lang graph we are using each of these
component as a nodes. So blueprint
generator, planner, executor and joiner
are all nodes on the langraph.
When building this uh tools in in your
enterprises around microservices,
probably this is where you will spend
most of your time.
And it's important to consider how this
relation between tools and microservices
goes. And here the relationship is
definitely not one to one or end to end.
It's end to end. It's up to you how you
want to design your tools according to
your microservices so that your agent
knows how to use this tool. Perhaps this
is like the most key point here that you
need to make really put yourself into
agent's shoes so that agent really
understand what tool to use and it has
that knowledge of your microservices.
Always follow standard. I know MCP is
everyone's favorite. So build the MCP
tool server for your tools. And for
providing the tool details just think
from agent's point of view that you need
to provide it tool purpose description
and input output contracts. So tool
purpose will help you what tools to be
selected. Tool detail description will
tell you when these tools need to be
invoked and input output contracts will
tell you how to use this tool. And
lastly add some validation checks which
acts as a break for your agent.
Now I would like to little bit zoom in
into this blueprint uh because this is
like one of the key architecture change
that we made. Uh blueprint is just a
series of steps for workflow as per tool
capabilities in natural language and
it gets fed to planner. But why we are
doing it? So what we realized was
planner really gets cognitively uh
loaded uh when you try to just put too
much onto it. So introducing a blueprint
which is just a natural language of
breaking down of a task is very helpful
but we also noticed that it brings lot
of other benefits as well. For example,
it achieves the final control over task
planning. it limits the in context tool
for the planner. So when blueprint you
can select what tools to be need to be
given to the planner and sometimes this
uh planners has lot of tool description
and you run all sort of problems as
context window limit and planner game uh
getting very much overloaded. So using
blueprint you can limit what tools
really goes to the uh planner and thus
uh it really helps in in the planning.
It also helps interpreting the agentic
behavior and lastly when you need to
collaborate with nontechnical
uh people it's like really helpful
because natural language is less
intimidating.
Let's see a concrete example. So in
financial research preparing for an uh
company's earning call is a common
workflow. So this is a very very
simplified version of
uh workflow of preparing for a company's
earning call. And for example we are
showing you preparing for NVIDIA as an
call.
Now you can see in the blueprint there
is a tool and there is task and in the
plan there is a tool and the function
call. So how does it look in in the
blueprint is you have two tools and then
you are first step as summarizing the
NVIDIA's previous earning call and the
next step is retrieval gathering some of
the financial data from uh for NVDI and
then your reasoning suggesting some
questions for the earning call and
finally reporting uh generate a
comprehensive report from the all the
information
and there are corresponding function
calls and as you can see context is
being fed from uh task
A a concrete uh example of the response
is before you implement agentic workflow
the response is pretty much vanilla but
after this it can easily capture your
workflow and give a very structured
response.
So whatever we talked about none of this
will really work without writing a
proper evals. So always make sure to
invest and build and maintain your eval
framework. You should have at least
component and end to-end evals.
You should really use the correct
techniques like codebased LMS judge
human in the loop and more importantly
write evals for metrics that you really
care for. Aspect bus eval is something
like we should really uh think about and
for example for blueprint
uh you can check an aspect like how many
uh blueprint whether resembles a golden
blueprint or not and you can use LM as a
judge. If you want to see whether tools
are selected correct or not you should
leverage code based evals.
If you want to check whether plan is in
line with the blueprint or not, LLM as a
judge probably the right technique. And
for some cases, leveraging human in the
loop is good because report formatting
uh that's the best approach to deal with
report formatting.
So when not to use agentic workflows. So
in some cases definitely agentic
workflow doesn't make sense. In case of
fixed and repetitive task just probably
go for ETL pipelines.
If your workflow cannot be really
captured, uh you cannot really capture
use case in workflows, agentic workflows
are probably not worth and if
deterministic outcome is paramount in
cases of strict compliance and safety
critical context, uh you should probably
should not go with agentic workflow and
in case of low latency and cost
environment also uh you should probably
try to avoid agentic workflow.
So wrapping up some learnings um start
with simple blueprints work way work uh
work your way way up uh building a
complex rack system for the blueprints
use blueprint to reduce the in context
uh tools and provide the high level plan
to the planner
design tools from agent point of view u
always aim for the tool usage simplicity
implement safety guardrails
and eval observability and all the good
software engineering. Uh that should uh
help you a lot.
And from the whole uh presentation, the
key takeaways are agentic workflow is
planned and run by agent. Agentic
workflows bring the reliability
at scale and planning by subgoal
division is a key design pattern. Plan
and execute is a key agentic
architecture.
and build your tools to complement your
microservices.
Always try to leverage your
microservices in the tools and modify
your architecture to solve the problems.
Don't really shy away from changing
taking research paper and experimenting
on it. And finally, treat your evals
like first class citizen.
And with that, thank you very much for
your time.
All right.
Uh, thank you. Any questions? We have a
little bit of time to spare.
I have a question. Um,
do you on have um in top of our mind any
like a GitHub project or reference that
we can follow?
Sure. Sure. So if you just go back here
um I kind of shared some of the
links um
for the lang chain it it should have all
the code for these research paper and
that's probably the most you know best
place to start with this plan and
execute kind of agents.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
Uh all right. Um I guess one question I
would have for you is
the when you talk about MCP and other
forms of orchestration, what do you
foresee being the the primary method of
orchestration going forward? Is it going
to be langraph or some other?
Yeah, I think the answer is probably
like everything. MCP you use it so that
you provide a standard across the arc
and MCP will really help for
organization to you know build once use
it everywhere. uh you can have oftenimes
in organizations we see that uh people
just like trying to just use this
functionality in different AI apps but
if you can build an MCP around it you
can keep using it and obviously for
orchestration langraph is great and
whatever the other tools that you find
to solve your problem that will be also
u so the answer is probably there will
be like multiple things that is useful
it depends on your use case what is the
uh most optimal framework that you want
to use
amazing Thank you so much, Yuri.
[Music]